-Our next guests kick off
a U.S. tour in November.
Performing "Cloud 9"
from their album "Honeymoon,"
here's Beach Bunny!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I don't wanna seem
the way I do ♪
♪ But I'm confident
when I'm with you ♪
♪ Lately, all I feel
is bad and bruised ♪
♪ Tired of tripping
on my shoes ♪
♪ But when he loves me,
I feel like I'm floating ♪
♪ When he calls me pretty,
I feel like somebody ♪
♪ Even when we fade
eventually to nothing ♪
♪ You will always be
my favorite form of loving ♪
♪ When I start to tumble
from the sky ♪
♪ You remind me how to fly ♪
♪ Lately, I've been
feeling unalive ♪
♪ But you bring me
back to life ♪
♪ But when he loves me,
I feel like I'm floating ♪
♪ When he calls me pretty,
I feel like somebody ♪
♪ Even when we fade
eventually to nothing ♪
♪ You will always be
my favorite form of loving ♪
♪♪
♪ But when he loves me,
I feel like I'm floating ♪
♪ When he calls me pretty,
I feel like somebody ♪
♪ Even when we fade
eventually to nothing ♪
♪ You will always be
my favorite form of loving ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]